die tomaten sind meine sind leckere
bonbons lutscher und herzlich willkommen
hier heute zu einem neuen blog meine
damen und herren es bereits im titel
eingeblendet heute werde ich 24 stunden
veganen leben außerdem werde ich euch
heute von dem road trip erzählen wo ich
im letzten block schon mal kurz
angedeutet aber hey ich sandra sarah im
juli parole aus wir jetzt haben geplant
wir sind mehr oder weniger fertig mit
der planung dann kann ich euch nachher
nochmal ein bisschen was zu erzählen was
war genau geplant ist auch block
technisch ich will jetzt erst mal die
hand ich würde sagen dass anderer kann
während das ein bisschen bloggen
wir müssen hat die bettwäsche beziehen
weil luca das nicht hinbekommt
doch die scharfen carola die einfach
gepasst doch in gelber fleck
also sage ich auf meinem pc
erst einmal aufgefallen dass jugend sich
immer von unten film hört jetzt mal auch
mit dem film bevor ich überhaupt etwas
passiert in diesem blog meine damen und
herren machen wir verdammt ich ernähre
mich ja wegen aller bildschirm zuvor
noch einfach zu hoch das einzig legale
dass ich habe es also der es schmeckt
gut und sandra allerdings auch hunger
haben und ich auch noch ein bisschen
hunger habe ich meine ich habe es ja nur
ein smoothie getrunken habt ihr euch
entschieden mitgenommen weil er
unterstütze dessen was die anderen ist
ein schnitzel ich würde wahrscheinlich
denken kleinen salat essen dann werde
ich wirklich in einem
bester bio markt gehen und uns egal
einkaufen wir sind im restaurant
angekommen jude hat sich ein schnitzel
bestellt da hat sich jetzt gestellt
andere hat sich hähnchenbrustfilets über
nackenbeschwerden ich es einen kleinen
beil hat ein schöner kleiner
beilagensalat crispy rob ist übrigens
auch mit dabei
mal bist du bescheuert hauptsache wir
sind hier drin in so einem möbelgeschäft
produkt um uns andere städte wuchsen
sandra kommen wir wollen weiter also ich
habe es bisher heute ein smoothie
getrunken sind klein und beilagen salat
gegessen
auf jeden fall gehen wir jetzt noch in
so einem biomarkt weil ich noch nicht
ganz einfach noch nicht gegessen war
also wusste ja dass du kein auto fahren
kann aber das ist uns erst mal leisten
können egal was ist das schreiben
übrigens auch immer voll viele leute die
kommentare das andere ich den eigenen
persönlich überhaupt dass du den eigenen
youtube kanal machen sollst du hast mal
leichter wenn wir jetzt anderen kanal
machen sollen freunde dann würde ich
nämlich irgendwie eine kamera
organisieren und dann vielleicht auch
lassen wir sind im bio markt angekommen
wo vegan vegan freunde also reißt wenn
nämlich mir auf jeden fall schon mal das
kleid ist halt wirklich in diesem laden
dass man überall was veganes oder was
halt nicht vegan ist steht zum beispiel
nur an das protein freies hier steht
dann das vegan und glutenfrei wie kann
ich habe gesagt die hier können wir auf
jeden fall holen oder hier steht organic
bio und hier steht dran vegan alter das
ist ja so das ding alle die nicht vegan
leben denken dass man dann nur noch prof
ich habe zwar gesagt 24 stunden egal
aber ich werde nicht mehr so was rein
pfeifen hier sehen sie so kann er sich
vegane nein meine sind lecker
donka wo k du hast alter der laden ist
mir sympathisch ich also auch kein kurs
dann können wir uns hier noch so ein
soja joghurt was gibt's denn hier mango
pietsch ich würd sagen der kasten wir
haben noch so veganes bio fruchteis
entdeckt also warum wir uns jetzt auch
noch so war es das erste mal dass sich
veganes als freunde
es schmeckt auch nicht gut 19 mal
schmeckt viel zu krank macht himbeer
mittel irgendwann wir selbst vegan
lebende leichte enttäuschung was ist ein
wandelnder kurzer nachtruhe
das hat nichts mit der wassermelone zu
tun sondern machten sich mit kuchen
ich habe einfach heute bisher so 1 die
getrunken einen kleinen beilagensalat
gegessen und ein veganes sgs und sandra
ist vorhin so jähnichen brust überbacken
mit käse und beschwerden jetzt daheim
als so war wieder alles selbst jude ich
habe gar eine folge des ewz gekuckt
sandra mittlerweile abgecheckt um einen
wagen explodiert gerade wie soll denn
explodieren des trainings drin dass hier
werden wir kochen meine damen und herren
einmal hier so veganen nudeln ein ganz
normaler spaghetti mittel dann haben wir
hier eine echt mimi kleine zucchini
kulakow guardiola wir haben wir so
tomaten werden ein bisschen klein
schneiden und dann haben wir hier ein
veganes pesto verde
[Musik]
meine damen und herren herzlich
willkommen zu wigan kochen mit luca
dafür erst mal einen topf packen dort
endlich wasser rein was ich sehr gut
das ganze hier stellen wir jetzt mal an
bringen wir zum kochen dann brauchen wir
noch so eine kleine dinge passiert die
tomaten und zucchini schneidet werden
zunächst einmal stehen wir allerdings
die ganzen hoch ist das ganze gewese
haben tomaten werde ich jetzt erstmal
klein schneiden die kommen alle zusammen
mit der zucchini die wir hier haben
hätten eine zwiebel kaufen können meine
damen und herren das wasser fängt an zu
kochen
wir haben die tomaten hier schon mal
fertig geschnitten das ist bringt kein
placement für schnitzer glutenfrei oder
den biomarker in dem die waren oder
keine ahnung was sondern wir testen das
ganze einfach mal was kann man das ja
aus wie dieser haken die man so in den
rasen macht wenn man ein klick ins spiel
wird sagt dem ich heute morgen hat
wirklich nur ein kleines muti getrunken
habe und als wir essen war nicht nur
beilagen vergessen habe und dann waren
wir den supermarkt habe ich noch ein
kleines eis gegessen da fragt alles
nicht so das wahre deswegen hoffe ich
dass das jetzt schmecken wir also leute
einige zeit vergangen
die nudeln sind in dem topf hier darin
die kosten gerade schön vorsichtig ii
habe ich fertig geschnitten
hier in der ferne sind die sonst hier
vorne haben wir die tomaten
das heißt ich werde warten müssen dann
kommen die zucchini werden dann
angebraten und dann kommen die tomaten
dazu in der zwischenzeit
die machen
sag's euch jetzt mal freunde also hört
mal genutzten richtig klasse englisch
stellen sich alle haare wäre die nudeln
hier vorne so ein bisschen vor sich hin
kochen essen wir eine legale waffe mit
mehr
der sonst so viel mit dem rad aber ohne
geht ja auch eigentlich minute sind so
gut wie zärtlich deswegen werde ich
jetzt möglich zucchini hier so ein
bisschen drauf packen auf den herd sache
dessen oder das mit der lüftung alles so
ein bisschen lautet und vor allem auch
der mit mit ich hoffe dass zu ende und
wir sehen uns wenn es fertig ist drei
solchen später minuten sind fertig
freunde also seht ihr hier vorne
die haben jetzt schon mal raus genommen
dass die muscheln kommen hier als erstes
auf international 250 gramm nicht mehr
gemacht habe ich glaube die werde ich
auch komplett schaffen web hat hunger
also allein die konsistent ist schon
anders als bei normalen spaghetti nudeln
und so sieht unser veganes gäste aus mit
zucchini tomaten und diesen pesto verde
das heißt davon kommt jetzt auch immer
so ein bisschen noch ein bisschen
pfeffer darüber und noch auch ein wenig
salz ihr darüber meine damen und herren
und dann kann ich euch nun präsentieren
meine erste richtige vegane selbst
gekochte mahlzeit
[Musik]
kein sommer ein veganes getränk beim
einem veganen essen ich bin echt
gespannt wie das ganze schmecken wird
also es sieht wirklich genauso aus wie
ein gericht was ich mir allgemein ganz
gerne koche normalerweise würde ich das
allerdings noch mit hähnchenbrust machen
allerdings hier mein erstes mal veganen
nudeln mit einem veganen pesto auf
geht's genau gleich ehrlich gesagt
schmeckt sogar geil weil die nudeln auf
jeden fall leider sind diese karten nur
wirklich mal probiert das ganze hier
jetzt mal eben halt beide nicht
vegetarisch auch nicht gerne mit den
beiden wirklich sehr gerne fisch fleisch
muss man muss mir leider zugeben aber
jude was sagst du zu den nudeln
ich find die nudeln gut aber dass pastor
mag ich nicht aber ich glaube durch
liegt ein pesto selbst nämlich gar
nichts gegangen ich bin ehrlich gesagt
auch mehr sondern von so roten pastor
also irgendwie dann noch mit hackfleisch
darüber dass zumindest in der polonaise
es probiert mal automatik herum
und jetzt mal die tomate also meine
zucchini ich bin ganz ehrlich ich selber
würde nie vegan leben können weil
vegetarisch kann ich mir nicht
vorstellen weil es ja auch hart genug
sind der kann man so was was vegetarisch
könnte ich mir auf jeden fall noch
vorstellen weil man da wirklich in
restaurant gehen kann und sagen kann ja
irgendwas ohne fleisch und fisch so ende
aber weil vegan und hat es ja auch sein
dass du irgendwas ist und du denkst es
vegane dass da irgendwie doch nicht
vegan
so beispielsweise auch nudeln oder so
was kann ich halt nie verzichten aber
ich bin ganz hell freunde das was ich
hier jetzt gerade gekocht habe und das
hat wirklich da sie viele sagen ob das
ist total schwer begannen zu kochen oder
vegan zudem oder so das war echte sie
unterschlägt sozusagen meine damen und
herren das war kochen mit luca
[Musik]
jetzt macht spaß ist übrigens
mittlerweile auf dem fahrrad unterwegs
wir fahren jetzt sonnenberg hoch
sie werden ich kann mich auf der stelle
wir sind hohen berg angekommen und
ehrlich gesagt ist das hier wirklich
einer meiner lieblingsorte können wir
sind zwar hier überall hoch gefahren
aber da hinten hat meine heftige
aussicht vielleicht gerade wegen der
belichtung nicht aber was man auf jeden
fall sieht ist wenn man täglich treppe
runter geht sieht man hier krass weit
und dahinten dass sogar der dunkel wir
machen uns hier gerade schon so ein
bisschen was zu essen da vorne also wir
machen uns was man mitmachen kartoffeln
mit gemüse unseren veganen currysauce
essen ist fertig freunde wir haben
reiste wir haben kartoffeln und wir
haben so tief gefrorenen blumenkohl
brokkoli karotten und halt diese vegane
currysauce und das probiere ich jetzt
mal das schmeckt ja durcheinander aber
auf jeden fall megageil und wenn ich
überlege dass jetzt gerade joggen waren
und ich jemand bin der sehr sehr viel
ist sich man schaut euch diese schale an
und das ist alles vegan und ganz im
ernst es ist nicht schwer vegan zu leben
ich habe es wirklich selber die ganze
zeit gedacht sowie ghana handy müssen
nicht nur darauf achten kein stein
bleibt also sondern auch alle tierischen
produkte nicht also nicht mal ganz
normal den nudeln oder milch oder keine
ahnung was das geht echt wahr
aufgegessen habe ich freunde allerdings
noch nicht ganz denn wir haben noch
einen unfassbaren
soja joghurt gekauft selbstverständlich
auch veganen ist definitiv westafrika
egal ob fit aus aber ich bin jetzt
ehrlich ich hatte dieses vorurteil ich
hatte diesen gedanken das vegan leben
echt heißt nicht so geil essen und nicht
so schnell im supermarkt gehen und
schnell man den kopf aber es ist möglich
es schmeckt gut und ich könnte juli so
betreiben die alle ja luca nennwert auch
veganer ja irgendwann mal macht
natürlich jetzt weiß ich warum es bei
vielen leuten gerade im internet so
komplettes no go ist so veganer hellweg
hier gibt es viele leute die darüber
hetzen aber leute schreibt mir meine
kommentare seit ihr veganer fakt euch
sowas ab steht die da drüber und gebt
mir noch ein paar vegane gerichte weil
das heute mittag war echt mega geil an
dieser stelle wünschen heutigen blog
jetzt allerdings auch beenden meine
damen und herren es war auf jeden fall
mal mega interessant einfach nur mal so
einen tag vegan zu leben ich weiß wenn
man das richtig machen will dann macht
man das eine woche oder monat oder noch
länger
oder das ganze so richtig für sich
herauszufinden und zu schauen wie das
ganze funktioniert aber das ganze aber
hey 24 stunden anfang vielleicht mache
ich irgendwann bei längerer allerdings
habt ihr jetzt wieder die möglichkeit zu
bestimmen was sich im nächsten block
machen soll dieses kind sie stunden
vegan leben wo ja auch von euch im
letzten block bestimmt am ende
wegen einer umfrage ein gewählt da könnt
ihr egal auf pc oder handy oder was weiß
ich was einfach draufklicken und
abstimmen was im nächsten blog das thema
sein so wie und weniger dabei sei doch
irgendwelche sachen drauf zu drücken
unter den videos auf so eine glocke da
werdet ihr benachrichtigt wenn ich das
hochlager also dann könnt ihr als erstes
neue meine videos sehen auch eine mega
tolle funktion aber ich würde jetzt
erstmal den block beenden
[Musik]